chantre dans le tennis moi j'attends su
me dirige vers une des onze chansons
auraient les patients peuvent pousser je
m'en vais
deux caméras et un trépied au docteur
patrick belmore de l'hôpital sacré coeur
c'est lui qui va être nos yeux et nos
oreilles à l'intérieur de l'hôpital
étant donné que les journalistes et les
familles n'y ont pas accès et bien sûr
tout ce matériel va être désinfectée
pour les fins d'exercice je m' improvise
caméraman ses deux succès à l'air un
déguisement kévin frenchy
vous réalisez pas les changements qui
ont dû s'opérer à une vitesse incroyable
et des changements structurels qu'on a
dû qu'on a dû opérer en quelques jours
alors que c'est des choses qui
généralement prennent des mois réalisée
au début de la pandémie l'hôpital
sacré-coeur de montréal n'étaient pas
destinées dans le centre névralgique du
combat contre la cofidis et donc il est
aujourd'hui au des établissements qui
accueillent le plus de cas au québec
bien deux modules qui ont été
complètement converti pour héberger de
la clientèle kevin o'keeffe et non entre
dans la charge qui donne sur une de nos
corps de fachan covin c'est bon on entre
dans la zone chaude
ici toutes les procédures ont été revus
pour éviter de contaminer le personnel
les patients infectés sont regroupés les
entrées sorties sont réduites au strict
minimum
witt l'environnement été réaménagé
rapidement pour créer chez tong hon
impression négative
l'air de la pièce et d'aspirer douze
fois par un puissant parrain
environnement soit par un système de
canalisation qui est filtrée époque
l'hôpital est passé de 5 à près de 130
salles à pression négative pour
accueillir les patients atteints d'un
kobe disney des patients sont cooptés
issue sous respirateur affronte à
proximité les uns les autres monsieur
les patients sont tous porteurs d'un
choriste et vent qui sont gérés encore
l'observation se fait par
vidéosurveillance et les communications
par interphone aux problèmes ont
notablement enchanté
c'est l'endroit où l'ennemi le plus armé
pour nous tirer dessus et on se demande
avec de ce point de vue là je me sens un
peu au front mais je pense que le québec
au complet au front et à l'hôpital du
sacré coeur ils sont tous cette armée
professionnelle à combattre le virus
il ya beaucoup de personnel actuellement
qui se synchronise avec le personnel ont
eu chaud
qui sont ancrées de confier les entrées
sorties de la zone pour aller s'occuper
de patients qui sont ventilés
mécaniquement le dr bellemare en général
disent faire preuve de leadership et de
créativité pour revoir les soins
intensifs de tous les hôpitaux du sud
nord de l'île de montréal pour combattre
un ennemi qu'on apprend encore à
connaître
j'étais très insomniaques à l'idée de
seniors face
à l'idée de ne pas être à la hauteur
puis quand je parle avec mary chain qui
sont qui sont au front actuellement
yoshi part de pas être à la hauteur
ce qu'ils veulent c'est qu'ils veulent
pas de perte de patients pour rien puis
à date on y arrive on y arrive très bien
[Musique]